do I have any tips for starting the day
positively in this coronavirus situation
like every day I do and take the cold
shower I take the cold shower which
wakes me up and then I want to go
everywhere because I got so much energy
now I go into breathing breathing
exercises and from the breathing
exercises which tilts my mind in the
deep I'm suddenly aware and just being
there being here amazing feeling that's
the way to start the day eventually a
push-up exercise after doing 30 breaths
is an amazing jolt of adrenaline rushing
through you then you are able to start
into any other way because you have
still Germont and you have still your
body through the cold shower the
breathing exercises and the push ups
exercise you're really on from there we
can go anywhere this is the way I start
my day every day we know the basics wash
your hands stay at home stay away from
other people try to you know maintain a
world where people are moving as little
as possible but but what do you think
we're missing that that people might
make a mistake and and and exacerbate
what we're going through now well I the
thing that needs to get fixed in the
next few weeks is to prioritize our
testing capacity which is going up but
making sure the right people are being
tested that will guide us in in a very
deep way and who are the right people if
you're symptomatic or somebody you've
been in close contact with tested
positive you know those are the broad
categories of course in the front of the
line you have health workers or
essential workers who have to go you
know keep the food supply the medical
system water electricity internet keep
those things running for the people who
are mostly at home but that doesn't use
up that higher percentage of
the testing capacity we have a lot of
people without symptoms who are just
kind of worried and there we need to
show them that until our capacity goes
up a lot they are going to have to wait
the worst thing we have is that if it
takes you 124 hours to get the test
result then you don't know you have been
told during the very key period where
your most infectious to take extreme
measures and so we've got to get not
just the numbers up that that confuses
people it's the speed of the result
South Korea was giving those results in
less than 24 hours
I feel like Mother Nature like no you
know you're on timeout
go to the corner think about what you've
done
but that's that's definitely what's
going on right now and we're seeing
these news reports coming out about how
the air is cleaning and you know the
ozone holes are shrinking and you know
the planet is resetting and the message
is pretty loud and clear that the earth
doesn't need us and is frankly much
better off without us and it's pretty
remarkable and dramatic than in such a
short period of time we're seeing these
kind of climate improvements and I think
that that should give us pause and
Ronnie Gus sit with that and reflect on
you know our habits and our addictions
and our lifestyle that's you know
created this situation that we find
ourselves in yeah what we were doing is
clearly unsustainable you know this this
profiting off of the suffering of people
on the planet it's not working and so
you know for a person to make a systemic
change in their life they usually have
to face some sort of a trauma and then
they have a period of time in that
trauma that wakes them up out of their
normal routines where they have an
opportunity to make a real shift and if
they do that shift can last for the rest
of their lives and if they don't they
can fall back asleep
again and sometimes they won't get
another chance to have that opportunity
for a big shift for another ten years
and I feel like an individual is like a
collective and this is our collective
opportunity to make systemic change and
I hope that we evolve rather involve I
think you know well being sensitive to
the many people out there who have you
know perhaps lost their jobs or you know
might be suffering from this illness
right now or have one that is you know I
have these kind of warring voices in my
head on the one hand you know I hear you
loud and clear and you know 100% that
that this is a this is this grand
opportunity for us all to you kind of
reflect on both our individual choices
and the systemic choices that our
culture has made that have led us to
this point and perhaps you know kind of
congeal us around more communitarian
approach to how we move forward so that
we can create more sustainable systems
and tread light more lightly on the
planet and kind of rethink our own you
know personal daily routines that leave
us you know kind of separated from our
divinity and yet on the other hand
where's the other voice that's saying
yeah but you know as soon as this thing
is over humans are gonna be scrambling
to just get back to to normal like how
do we get back to the way things were
how can I you know book that that that
vacation on the cruise liner and you
know all the stuff right like we have
this and me human beings are incredibly
resilient but we also have shortened
Marines when it comes to this kind of
thing and my fear is that we'll get to
the other side this will pass and we
will you know not learn the lesson that
that's being presented to us right now
how concerned are you about the
coronavirus situation warren well you
got to defer to the doctors on that but
you know you can get into all these
figures about I flew regularly kills you
know 20 times as many people in this
country
r14 eyes maybe as much as we've seen in
the way of deaths even more than that
but you know it is a pandemic I mean I
don't know exactly what the dictionary
definition is but well you have
something that's in China and Korea and
Italy and Iran I mean it's it's it's a
it would meet my definition of a
pandemic it's something that and and
it's no one knows the duration or
dimensions of it now you can't know at
this point and what you do know is that
the dimensions have changed since a few
months ago and haven't changed in in
terms of the possible worst-case but
they but the best case is moving over in
that it's spread and you know Italy's
them a good example I mean it is a
really spread so we we've got something
that we don't know how long it'll be
with us we don't know how severe it will
be but there will be uncertainty about
that for a considerable period of time
there has to be what precautions are you
taking personally or if you think
they're habits well I'm drinking a
little more coca-cola actually seems to
ward it off everything else in life I
mean I'm 18 I'm and I just had had two
different doctors tell me I'm in much
better shape than I was a few years ago
I'm not sure what I'm doing to get a
better shape but by accident I mean I
had an annual heart check where I wear
something around my waist for a couple
the guy said money
it's never good better so no I really
I'm a probabilities guy and by nature so
I you know I I there's going to be to
2.8 million deaths this year and at age
18 I was a little more likely to be that
wasn't that group but two million eight
you know and what we had so far I mean
it it will grow but in terms of changing
my life I haven't really changed but I
could work at home easily and so good
people know what are the things that you
do when you're under pressure to stay
calm to stay in tune with your mind and
not let your emotions overpower you okay
yeah I've been getting that question a
lot first I just want to make sure can
everyone can you hear me well am i
sounding good just like any
fantastically okay good um so yeah so a
lot of people are having anxiety a lot
of fear so there's just some practical
things I'm going to share for for you to
do to kind of help manage that I think
the first and most important thing is
think about what you're watching on TV a
lot of folks have the news on and I get
it I do news you know I go on air and I
talk about certain things but they have
been used on all day long and it's
constant barrage of Korona the virus the
pandemic all these people are ill all
the stuff is happening and that in and
of itself is going to give you more fear
and more anxiety so you can watch the
news watch it read through it get the
information you need update yourself and
then stop you should not be watching it
constantly you should be binging on
shows that help you break away
you should be maintaining other things
but you should not be watching the news
on a consistent cycle that is extremely
negative and more importantly at night I
never watch the news unless I'm on but
unless I'm on it covering something but
I won't not watch the news I think you
have to think about the mindset you put
yourself in before you go to bed and I
have a ritual that I do at night before
I go to bed so that's the number one
thing I'm gonna tell you don't watch the
news on a cycle go in get briefed and
the same with social media get the
information you need and then stop okay
too much of a barrage of everything is
gonna be negative it's gonna impact
anybody would impact me if I sat and
watch the news consistently it would
have an effect on me the other thing is
think about the situation wearing in
that you've got all this time now and we
always say you know if I had the time I
would do this so find that time find
value in what's happening if it's just
like oh my gosh I can't believe this is
happening then you have no meaning if
you can find meaning
what's happening saying that do the
things you always wanted to do if you
wanted to learn another language learn
that other language if you wanted to
learn to play the guitar learn to play
the guitar do the things you always
wanted to do be productive in this time
so having moments where you binge watch
Netflix or a great show here and there
that's great
but do that moderately use this time in
a productive way and actually research
shows that we are most productive and
created what creative when we we do
things alone so this is that time to do
those things those are like the most
important things I think again at night
I think the way the minds that you have
when you go to bed at night is super
important so for example I have a ritual
at night I work out at night I'm not a
morning person so that's just how I
operate so I will do I will do my
workout at night mmm followed by my
workout I will do my cold shower at
night depends how brave I'm feeling
sometimes it's 30 seconds sometimes it's
a minute sometimes it's five depends
where I'm at and then I'll do my
meditation so those are the three things
I do to put myself before I go to bed at
night and so find your own ritual it
doesn't have to be like mine that you
prep your mind so that you can sleep
well because when you sleep well you're
calm you get rest and then you wake up
the next day and you're feeling good you
have a more positive outlook on things
if you want more advice wisdom guidance
from other successful entrepreneurs on
how you can navigate the coronavirus
situation check out the video right
there next to me I hope you find it
valuable and continue to believe and
I'll see you there where you predicted
pretty much what is happening now